[Music]
joining me today is an author a radio
and podcast host and the executive
chairman of the Iran Institute you're on
Brooke welcome back to the Rubin report
thanks thanks for having me back
normally I don't let people back but I'm
willing to make an exception I
appreciate that all right we got a lot
to talk about and first I'm going to
tell a little bit of a story that that
you know and for those that watched the
stream that I did a toke on which is the
objector conference in Pittsburgh last
month I told the story but I just want
to reiterate a while I'm sitting here
with you now that you are on this show
for the first time in May of 2016 so
about year and three months ago or so
and I was in the midst I had just sort
of been thinking about maybe leaving or
a TV which is the network that we were
on a place that I loved being at that
Larry King had brought me into that I
felt we were growing and all that but at
the same time I realized we were growing
so rapidly there was so much happening I
wanted to own and control what I was
doing and all this stuff I sit down with
you lay out rational self-interest you
lay out the tenets of Objectivism you
lay out a lot of issues about capitalism
and taxes and all of these things and I
finished that interview like said
goodbye do we shook hands and I walked
into the control room and I said to my
guys I think it's time to go I hope
you're going to come with me
fortunately they all did come with me we
ended up going on patreon became fans
funded that's over a year ago now the
rest is history so I do connect some of
my current success to sitting down with
you in the first place well I appreciate
that and and thanks for telling the
story and it was it was fun because I
think I got a phone call from you either
that day and my joy as I'm driving all
night a day certainly within the day
within it within a day or two saying you
know I'm leaving yeah and you're very
courageous of you and I'm thrilled that
it worked out so amazingly well yeah you
must love I'm sure that's not a first
time that you know someone listen to you
speak and then it affected the way they
actually opted not just the way they
think that that's the important thing
I've had many guests come in here
that affect the way I think make me
think different things or change my
thoughts or sometimes it reinforces the
thought whatever it is but you must
appreciate that more that helps when
someone goes I heard you and let me put
this stuff into action yes I mean when
somebody comes and says I heard you and
as a consequence of that I did XYZ and
it changed my life there's nothing more
satisfying as a teacher as a lecturer as
a you know as a commentator then having
something like that 9r and got a lot of
that right she changed my life she
changed everything about what happened
in my life but but for me as you know
I'm not an originator of ideas I'm over
communicative of ideas it's incredibly
satisfying it's it's it's it's the
funnest thing that happens so we're
going to talk about a lot of stuff here
what I what I don't want to do is I
don't want to just focus on the same
ideas of Iran that we discussed the
first time we will link to our original
interview below so shrimpo want the full
catch up we're going to do a little bit
but I don't want to just you know
repackage what we did last time so I
thought the best place to start off is
that most of my audience knows I am
doing monthly events with you guys with
a RI where we're really focusing on free
speech and I've been usually with Steve
Simpson and then we brought a few people
that I've done shows with we've kind of
Michael Shermer and Colin Moriarty and a
bunch of people we have Brett Weinstein
coming on working on a few others and
when I when they proposed this idea to
me I said well look if if we're going to
focus on free speech and really just
allow us to say whatever we want and
talk about why that's important to do it
how does free speech fit into
objectivism into Iran's ideology and
into your ideology well it's it's a
cornerstone of the ideology in terms of
the application of it objectivism is
about reason it's about using your mind
it's about using your mind and the
ability of our senses and our mind to
discover reality we need to be able to
express that in some way through action
through speech writing books writing
articles we need to be able to
communicate those truths that we
discover and the human mind is capable
of knowing the world but if it just
stays in the mind what's the point
and if they are salaries out it they can
tell you no no that idea is unacceptable
you have to be in house arrest in the
case of gallows oh oh we can actually
burn you at the stake
then you're shutting down the human mind
people will not think now it's true that
it's part of the freedom to speak but
think a lot of bad ideas are going to
come up right a lot of untruths a lot of
garbage fine but in order to strike
towards truth you're going to have to
let a lot of untruth be told we thought
we wouldn't be discussed you cannot
establish Authority the dictates what is
good what is true what is not true the
ultimate authority is reality
yeah are there any ideas that are too
dangerous to explore so when we've seen
bad ideas really truly bad ideas the
Holocaust is our Network into action
this started as an idea of course
heading and absolutely but but it's
taught as an idea in in the writings of
a philosopher in in my view you know 150
years before the Holocaust like but the
fact is really a rich philosopher I
think it's Immanuel Kant I think that
the guy who separates human reason from
reality the guy who says that morality
is about duty and who says that he's
trying to save faith save faith from the
tyranny of reason if you will is amount
of content I think he begins the long
chain of Hegel and Schopenhauer and Marx
and Nietzsche that ultimately leads I
think to the Nazi ideology but the fact
is that the only way to combat Kant's
the only way to combat Marx the only way
to combat Nietzsche the only way to
combat any of these ideas is what better
ideas is is is to engage once you
establish an authority that says no
can't you're going to lead to hit low
one day we have to silence you right
then you're ready establishing what
people want you establishing the
authority of you know somebody's mind
over other people's minds and that's
what that's what has to be banned it's
so interesting because there's a
if there's a play here that I think goes
well for for you guys as Objectivist
which is anytime someone brings up an R
and there's the select group of people
that like her that like the ideals they
want to hear that now but for most
people at least in the mainstream
there's an immediate dismissal oh that's
that child is stuff I all know that nice
school or college or blah blah and it's
all that is it's not a debate of ideas
that's just a shutdown of discussion
which is the complete reverse of what
you want and exactly and look if
somebody who advocates for radical ideas
and my ideas are radical they're
different from the mainstream the
different what people out they believe I
have to have free speech in order to be
able to advocate and be able to
hopefully change the world for the
better and advocate for the kind of
ideas that I believe it true and and
real and if we allow anybody to shut
down ideas I'm going to be among the
first victim so I have a clear selfish
interest in advocating for free speech
and in viewing I'm and viewed free
speech as if free speech goes then it
softer or Terina so my free speech goes
what is your only option right the only
option then to fight for whatever you
believe in is with a fist it's with a
gun it's revolution so free speech as
though it is is a recognition that the
only way we are going to change the
world is through discussion through
reason to fact without the use of fists
and guns as soon as that is gone as soon
as that is eliminated all that's left is
is violence and and that's of course you
know what we see on campuses what we're
seeing is the resorting to violence
because they've given up on reason
they've given up on speech they've given
up on discussion I don't know if you saw
this but about a month and a half ago
there was an article written in der
Spiegel about me and a few other people
and it was talking about this the rise
of the new alright which couldn't be
more absurd yes but I spent the entire
day with the author he watched me do two
shows here and then the evening was at
UCLA where I did an event with the iron
folks and I was on with with Colin and
and the way he wrote it was that we were
at some sort of far-right angry rally
and I thought the video is up there by
the way there's book and watching me
talk
nine ran is to channel page and it's
like people watch it this thing could
not have been a more glorious expression
of free speech but but even that shows
you what we're up against just this
constant miss truth throughout the media
right now that that's eroding our
ability to accept what facts are
absolutely and look I'm fine with
dealing with miss truth because the
truth will went out and we can debate
that what worries me is an op-ed in the
New York Times a few weeks ago that came
out that said explicitly that speech is
violence that is scary right because as
soon as they say you know so they call
you an outright what you know and you
say I'm not and fine but once they say
okay your ideas equivalent to violence
what they're legitimizing is using
violence against you and that is what is
really truly dangerous in this debate
and that's what's going on in Berkeley
and evergreen and all these other places
where the left these students feel
emboldened to being up baseball bats
yeah not to defend themselves against
somebody else who has a gun who has a
was another baseball bat but defend it
to defend themselves against being
offended by somebody else's speech
they've given up on reason they've given
up a debate they've given up on the
human mind and what Dad what presents is
a return to primitive brutishness right
to tribal warfare because it's not an
accident that the postmodern is all
about tribalism right this is about what
terms of tribalism where we hit each
other instead of debating each other in
the great achievement of the Western
civilization and I really consider
Western civilization achievement of
Greece and achievement of the
Enlightenment and the great achievement
in the Enlightenment is saying stop
killing each other over all ideas right
because if you think about the 17th
century more people died per capita in
the 17th century than maybe any other
century certainly in modern history
because Protestants and Catholics were
slaughtering each other and the line
that said stop with the violence
violence is anti like anti man which we
should ban it if we disagree let's
discuss it and let and let reality be
the judge of what is true and what isn't
and we're abandoning that magnificent
achievement of enlightenment do you pin
all of that on post-modernism well look
yet yes in this modern format but again
post-modernism is a consequence of a
long string of ideas that in a sense
goes back to Plato right you know it
goes back to Plato but I consider Plato
innocent right because he was such a
genius and he was so early in human
beings thinking big thoughts like
thinking philosophical ideas then any
errors he made we can forgive I can't be
that angry of Plato no he can't get mad
appear now once you get into the modern
era I start getting angry at people is
that because they've got we've got human
history you can look you can see you've
got you've got lots of examples of what
happens when you have bad ideas but if
you think about Plato's ideas plato
basically said that the truth is to be
found in a different dimension that the
world of forms is not the world we're
seeing so our senses our reason is not
seeing the world as it is and though we
only specialists call them philosophers
can actually see the truth so he has
this allegory of the cave where we're
all in the cave chained and all we see
are shadows and that's reality to us and
only if you go to the mouth of the cave
can you see the real world which is the
Sun only the philosopher can actually
see that that me is that we have to be
ruled by experts we have to be ruled by
these philosophers we have to be told
what reality is because we just to in a
sense and dumb or two we don't have the
revelation now that opens up there to
religion and everything right
revelations choose versus reality issues
I attribute all of these bad ideas in a
sense back to that some illogical
falsehood I think and then the post
modernists have just taken that and
turned it into you know it made it much
much worse but in some respects
consistent how much of that do you think
is just the top-down way of viewing the
world versus the bottom-up meaning
top-down meeting through either God or
some sort of religious construct as
opposed to viewing everything from the
end
vidual and from our own mind I think
it's all about that and and I think I
think it's basically the challenge is
what is human reason is is human reason
efficacious that's the fundamental
question and if you think about Plato
versus the Pierrot in my view
historically as Aristotle as Otto says
no reason is efficacious this is the
world we know the world by using our
senses and using our mind to understand
it know it not everything he said is I
think it's turned out right not
everything it says philosophic is right
was that subjective when he said that so
the person that's in the shackles
that's only seeing shadows that still is
their reality right it is but it's not
subjective in the sense that there is a
true reality she says there is a true
reality it's here this table actually
exists we're both you might see that
angle on it I might see this angle on it
but is if we use the tools of science we
can shake the table and agree on what
the table is and what it's composed of
and how it functions so that reality is
objective even though we might see
different sides of it our reality it is
it is objective and we have the tools
reason science to fully understand the
context of the table so for Aristotle
human reason and in our senses actually
reflect the reality as it is now again
he was influenced by Plato as a student
focusing fifteen years or something so
he was influenced by Plato so there's
some errors I think and whatever Stahl
advocates for bit but to me time and too
many thinkers I think the the real
battle of all Western history and
ultimately I think global history
because I think Western ideas are
spreading all over the world is a battle
between al estado and Plato between
whether reason is efficacious in this
world whether we see reality as it is
where the reality is objective where the
reality is independent of our
consciousness or whether you know we
need we need to to get knowledge from
some kind of other dimension that and
then you need the experts and then you
need the leaders and then you need you
need you know look if you look at Hitler
Hitler was just channeling
the truth for the Orient people to the
audience right he was the guy who had
the revelation if you will for the truth
today if you look at if you look at the
Communists well how do we know what the
politic need but you need somebody to
channel to get to somehow in some
mystical way to get to what is good for
the politician so you have a stall and
you have a Leonard you need a leader
you know I reject all of that Aristotle
would have rejected all of that you have
to discover the truth for yourself it is
your responsibility as a human being to
discover truth
I mean you shouldn't have to accept the
truth over the barrel of the gun you
shouldn't have to accept the truth of
the value of a gun or over you know over
the kind of social pressure that a
church or Communist Party or Hitler
Youth kind of dictate to you you should
use your mind as an independent human
being to go out there and discover what
is real and what is not what is right
and what it's not and and and discover
the values that are going to lead it
might you might be the purpose of
morality is to lead to your own
happiness to discover the values that
are going to make your life the best
life that it can be make your life
objectively the best life that it can be
is anything that you've said so far that
you believe in not an Enlightenment
value because for example I've had
several people come on the show who are
believers and who would argue that this
comes from a judeo-christian mindset and
I think you can make all of the I think
there's errors in that way of thinking
of though I can appreciate it
but I think every argument that you've
made has really been about enlightenment
is that is that fair no absolutely and
look I think there are a lot of
Christians and Jews who would like to
take their Christianity and Judaism and
massage it so it fits into the
Enlightenment values which they the good
in them responds to but it isn't there
now they're elements right the you
wouldn't Christian II wouldn't read
successful if it didn't have an element
of individualism in it to your
relationship with God as an individual
relation Judaism would have survived all
the years if it ended Apted cleverly to
kind of enlightenment values and embrace
Aristotle Maimonides was an institution
scholar so Judaism in some extent
embraced our style in different in
different stages so these religious
adapted and in one of the problems with
Islam is it didn't adapt it is sticking
to the the mystical dogma of its
founding rather than having adapted to
Aristotle to to these Enlightenment
dollars but yes all these ideas are at
the very least hinted at in the
Enlightenment now I don't believe
they're fleshed out in the Enlightenment
I think this is why when cons and
Schopenhauer and all of these guys who
are anti Enlightenment figures came
about the Enlightenment was weak in its
response because I don't think the
alignment it completely philosophically
fleshed out these ideas and I think that
it took Iran to really flesh out I view
Iran is philosophically the culmination
of the Enlightenment I think she's she
Rep there's a true representative of
those Enlightenment ideas fully fleshed
out fully understood and the first time
the first thing to really be able to
combat the ideas are Hegel in it and a
Nietzsche and a Marx an account and and
and and that's the power that's the
philosophical power that she had but yes
it's all there right the Declaration
dependence even though Molly if you'd
asked any one of the founders or if
you'd asked enlighten I think is what is
the purpose of morality they talk about
sacrifice and they talk about altruism
unity but in the Declaration they chose
to say that you have an inalienable
right to pursue you won't have it yeah
right so they understood and they they
had a deep understanding of the idea of
happiness as the as the purpose of
living is the purpose of life if I'm not
mistaken we're the only country in the
world perhaps in the history of the
world that has a line like that right
there is one of the country okay you're
going to blow my mind now there is a lot
of the country and it was it they didn't
they didn't choose it
it was crammed down their throat the
only country actually have it in the
Constitution is Japan and that's because
General MacArthur wrote a constitution
after World War two
the Japanese wrote a constitution Wakasa
said this is you know you have to change
all your ways you guys had a bad idea G
and bad ideas we crushed you guys you
have to change and basically McCausland
has a system sat down and they wrote
Japanese Constitution and in the
Constitution it says that you have any
nearly would like to pursue your
happiness and they basically forced it
down the empress throats and the
japanese have adopted it and I would
argue that Japan has succeeded as well
as it has succeeded because it basically
got a version of the American
Constitution do you think there's like a
little bit of a catch-22 with putting
happiness in a document like that like
on one hand it's like said you're
supposed to be happy about is great we
all want to be happy we want to find out
if but on another hand there's an odd
pressure that other country really that
other could use up like in other
countries you work you do what you do
you hopefully pilfer some happiness out
of existence but with less it's baked in
like there's opportunity for happiness
and maybe have maybe the human condition
at its most honest it I don't know that
it's happy you're not happy it just is
and you got to grab it because that a
strife or something right so it's not
happiness that's guaranteed in the
Declaration but it's a freedom yeah
which is what a right means what it
rights mean right means freedom of
action so you have free to act in
pursuit of your happiness that's
beautiful yeah I can't think of anything
more beautiful in a political document
then that every individual has a right
to act you know to pursue the rational
values that are necessary for his own
happiness now I put in an additional
words in there but I think that's at the
end of the day what the phone is
actually meant they wanted to create a
country where individuals could go and
they would be free to act on their own
behalf
in rationally they didn't they want
crooks they're only bad guys they don't
lazy people they wanted people actually
wanted a embrace life and go off and
achieve happiness and or at least strive
towards happiness and and and do the
best they could so you mentioned that
Iran did in your view the philosopher
who sort of pinned all this together so
now as I said without redoing everything
we did last time and again we will link
to it down below so that sometimes we
forget in people get this but we are
going to link to it down below can you
explain to me in just a couple of
minutes yeah what it is that Iran put
together I know I know it but for my
audience what Iran put together that you
view as the complete package or sort of
the end game of these enlightenment
values sure well let's let's
put it in the context of enlightenment
the enlightenment is still to large
extent in both a you know feels the
pressure from Christianity so Locke is
still a Christian or at least claims to
be and he's trying to philosophically
justify everything in terms of
Christianity and and even the founders
right as secular as I think they were
and as deist as they were they were
still they were still felt like at least
morality at least the certain elements
that they felt that they had to be
linked back to God which meant God was
mentioned a lot even though they had
separation the declaration advances
creator you know it doesn't say God but
which I think was important to them but
but at the end of the day yes I mean if
you read the Federalist paper view the
other things they clearly a referencing
a common understanding of Christianity
at the time I'm much more secular
understanding than 100 years previous
but it's still under the guise of the of
religion Iran you know secular rises
those ideas completely so she starts off
by saying reality is what it is that you
know nature's out there it's independent
of our consciousness each and this agree
she goes to Aristotle a is a this table
is here table is here and we can measure
its dimensions and we can understand it
scientifically and it is and we have the
ability to know the table right is here
you know you saw a census in Armonk so
our reasoning capacity tells us about
the world in its in sheet grounds and
she has a whole theory of concept
formations how we come up with a concept
of table and and how the mind in that
sense works there is a revolutionary
that did not existed before and really
is missing from from Lockean and the
enlightenment philosophy disconnection
of epistemology and metaphysics to the
politics okay and he says look reason
reason is it is a is a is a capacity of
the individual we don't have a collect
the stomach we don't have a collective
consciousness we don't have a collective
mind so reason is something individuals
do and and she places the the call of
morality with the individual right so
your purpose as a human being Molly if
to survive as a human being which means
to use your reason in order to guide
your life towards the goal which is
happiness and she bridges what in
philosophy is called the is odd
dichotomy can you take what exists out
there the condition of man has existed
in reality and it can you derive offs
from it and she says of course you can
we have a particular nature now the
study of ethics is the study of what is
that nature therefore what other virtues
and values we need to adopt in order to
stay in existence because we face this
alternative as living beings death yeah
we can go out of existence so she
bridges all of this and of course
connects all that ultimately to politics
so the biggest pushback I here against
that is that if it is all somehow just
left to us and left to our mind and
logic and reason all that that we the
mind plays tricks on us we all believe
different things we all get different
news sources we all are brought up in
different religions or non religions
whatever that the the system of so many
competing individuals will lead to some
sort of like mass chaos or something
well it turns out quite a contrary it
turns out when you leave people free and
you leave people free to think for
themselves you get beautiful things and
it is authoritarian it is the idea of an
authority the idea one way of thinking
of the world the idea of cramming down
our minds truth is what is destructive
to progress an ability to innovate and
create and build and make the fact that
we have different values the fact that
some people want to be doctors and other
people want to be architects and other
people want to be high tech
entrepreneurs creates the beautiful
world what we have to what we have to
accept a man would argue is that
morality right is objective just like
science teaches us about the physical
world morality should teach us about
what is good for us and what is bad for
us from the perspective of human action
from human thought and human action that
there's certain things that are wrong
that it Amahl that evil that are bad and
when those things get translated into
action then yeah then the state needs to
intervene and take
people put them in jail but they're
going to be bad people who are Baptists
and as long as they don't manifest them
into action I can say that person seemed
all but I can't do anything about it
unless he acts in a way that hurts
somebody else did violate somebody
else's rights so I think you may have
seen this but I had an interesting
debate a couple weeks ago between
Michael Shermer from skeptic magazine
yes and Dennis Prager who's a
conservative arguing but for that the
necessity now for God to have a live a
moral life now pretty clear which side
you're on on this well but I but I
disagree with both right okay because I
disagree with schirmer's basis for
establishing so that allows why I wanted
to get yeah so he's too much of a
skeptic in my view so he rejects and
this is the problem I think with a lot
of the new atheist is I find them
conventional when it comes to morality
and and this is the funny thing I find
it you know Harrison and Sherman and the
and Dawkins very Christian in them all
beliefs so they accept Christian
morality without attributing and of
course the Christianity they accept the
the commandments if you will Christian
morality without challenging them and
what what ran does what I really what do
you mean they accept them only as
exposed to accepting them as the values
of immediate lighting them as opposed to
rethinking it as opposed to say okay we
got a blank slate right we're going to
take science and apply it to Morelli
and so they accept for example the
sacrifice that selflessness is morally
good you can't justify that if you think
of morality from a scientific
perspective you can't justify that when
you think from an individualistic
perspective how can selflessness be a
good thing I am Here I am Alive it's
it's me shouldn't I care about my life
as the as the stand if there's no God
that I have to that I have to you know
adjust myself to that the baby is I is a
higher power more important than me
isn't my life the most important thing
in the universe
to me right and then based on that
shouldn't I then think okay
what are the values and virtues that my
life requires and that's it that I would
argue is a scientific question we have
to look at the world and see what works
for human being what doesn't violence
clearly doesn't work it's very
destructive reason you know every human
achievement every value everything we
have is a product of reason as I say
okay so if I care about my life what I
need to pursue more than anything else
is reason is is is my ability to
understand the world and then to try to
shape the world you know to make it
possible for me to live in it so I won't
presume to speak for any of those guys
either I've had both of them on the show
but so the other argument that I thought
was interesting so the Prager argument
in this case is that basically on the
macro level oh sorry I'm on the micro
level that yes we can have atheists and
non-believers and we can all pick our
own morality and that's all okay but
whose argument really is that on a
societal level that you need this
outside force basically to temper the
parts of humans that get out of control
sort of I so you've already sort of
answered this but is there anything you
want to kind of yeah and I think it's a
very bleak view of human nature and I
think that the many many kind of people
who are generally secular but really
believe in religion have you know
without religion or you know I can do
without religion but if those people
don't have religious they will all
become murderous crazy I don't have that
view of human beings I mean I respect
every individual and I view every
individual is capable of understanding
that going on a on a murderous rampage
is not good for them I think that if we
educated people well and if we held up
high expectation people would understand
that stealing lying and cheating is not
good for them that the negative
consequences that they would bear would
far exceed any superficial benefit they
might get from it and when I explain to
audiences look line just is a stupid
survival strategy it just doesn't work
it's not good for you it's not good for
you psychologically and Jordan Peterson
that on this show has some wonderful
segments on lying and what it does to
psychologically is a psychologist talk
about that so psychologically its
destructive exist entually nobody wants
to deal with you once you're caught you
always caught right or ultimately you
always got it just is a bad strategy so
what I want to do is say look people
instead of having to go to another power
or instead of saying there is no
morality or saying well well is
subjective whatever it whatever you feel
like I want to say let's use the same
tools that we use to evaluate other
things in likely to accept the objective
less yes you use those tools the tools
of reason to evaluate what leads to a
successful life and and and we might
disagree on some of those but at least
let's accept that the tool to evaluate
that is reason let's evaluate you know I
think we'll all agree that lying is not
good for you in my life so don't like I
think we'll all agree that facts a
better than falsehood - that's so
honesty is a broad concept which is not
just being honest other people but be
honest to yourself right we have to
agree what the facts are which is
becoming an increasing problem but sure
how we approach what are facts that is a
question of a personality it's a
question of science if you will let's
let let's deal with it like that I think
we can we can probably agree on that so
let's approach ethics from that basis
but let's start with the idea that it's
the individual as to survive it's
individual that has to thrive and it
turns out that in order for me to thrive
me thriving does not entail me
exploiting you me thriving does not tell
me lying and cheating and stealing and
murdering you quite the contrary meat
surviving and tells me trading with you
me me thriving entails meat creating as
many win-win mutually beneficial
situations as I can but not because I
love you like I love me I don't I don't
as much as I love you I know that were
only invited here I feel warmly but I
love myself more this whole idea of
loves I need I like yourself forget it
nobody loves a neighbor like they do
this nobody was self-esteem I loves the
neighbor like they do so then I asked I
just keep my Christian audiences asked
them okay
your kids are drowning in the pool the
neighbors kids are drawing your pool who
do you say first anybody saves their own
kids first and I say you shouldn't be
embarrassed about that fact you should
be proud of the fact that your kids you
love them more than your neighbors kids
it's okay to save them first could I
would also try to save the neighbors
kids but only after I saved mine I don't
even know that this is totally
irrelevant but could that desire be from
something that supersedes logic could
that simply just be something that caked
in to us well you know through genes and
evolution and everything is a matter I
mean this is part of the big question in
teresting scientific question what is
actually baked into us
I can't think less is baked into us than
a lot of scientists today think but I
think that's a scientific question that
needs to be worked out but begin at to
some extent look we love our kids
otherwise don't have them right yeah
because you're not going to treat them
well if you don't love them so we love
our kids and when we love something we
want to protect it we want to embrace it
we want to you know save it when it's in
harm's way we love like our neighbors
kids but it's just not going to be the
same so now it is true that there are
people you know there are mother Teresa
like people who will commit these acts
that know they'll let their kids die and
save the strangest kids because that's
the right thing to do now I view that as
awful of you that is evil right that you
would not take your life seriously
enough to save your kids before the
neighbors but there's some people and we
usually save them we usually you know
write them great honors who are willing
to sacrifice their life they values
everything they hold dear truly for the
sake of a stranger for the sake of
sometimes for the sake of nothing and
that's what religion does to people and
that's one of the things I think is a
hollow ball about religion is it
inculcates this idea that there has to
be something greater than yourself
[Music]